but we already have that example
remember
um the German Prime Minister
um Margaret Thatcher Margaret Thatcher
look list trust let's see what she's
doing yeah
um Angela Mark Angela Merkel yeah okay
Theresa May
I I think women come now I want to know
like what what do you think women would
do differently from men why they would
make better leaders
wait can I just answer the other
question first I feel like you'll give
an example of conservatives so it's like
I wouldn't think a conservative would be
a great leader anyway a conservative
woman yeah so you give them examples of
like Theresa May and stuff like that
like so you have to get a liberal woman
no I just I just don't think
conservatives is the best way for this
one okay no no we're talking about men
and women so what do you think is do you
think a liberal woman do better in wait
so conservative women don't count
no I think she means by the party
affiliation
do you want to labor you want a labor
party woman running a country yeah okay
even a labor party right so I'm asking
so what would she do differently what
would she do differently politically or
what would a woman do differently
because I think if we look at New
Zealand as a prime example they have
like one of the best responses to a lot
of things terrorism happens in a lot of
countries when it happens in the UK they
don't do really anything like they do
things about it it's always too late we
always get a terrorist attack something
will happen in New Zealand the first
time they had like an instance of a
terrorist that was this they went to
trial with him straight away they do
things way quicker this was on the news
it was a massive thing that was going on
everyone was praising the the leader of
New Zealand was she conservative or
laborer
she's a labor government is she still in
power now so so according to your logic
you're saying if we're going to get a
female leader we have to get a labor
female leader not a conservative one
because they'll do a bad job so when we
get a terrorist attack terrorist foreign
you seem to have a lot of pent-up anger
towards men I'm not angry I'm never
saying all men I'm saying certain men
like I I feel like if Jeremy corbyn was
running this the countries what if we
did that with race do you think people
would feel this type of way about it
have you said like a certain Race So if
you said not all of this race but a lot
of this race doesn't run the country
well
[Music]
yeah yeah but I'm saying like I'm saying
I'm wondering why is one okay but one
isn't it it seems like you're talking
about political affiliation because
powers are conservative woman I think
she'd run the country great
with her ideals I've had her ideals I've
heard what she thinks Society I've heard
the way she thinks about relationships
and the core structure he'd vote for me
yeah I'd vote for you like the more
structural society when it comes to
family nuclear family keeping it
together I think it's great it Canada
how Canada is handling it though like
they're just they're further destroying
the the nuclear family they're they're
encouraging uh I don't know if I can say
the word but like you know
people that like to mess with kids like
uh they're giving little kids uh
um puberty blockers right they're
they're essentially castrating the
little kids and these kids they they can
they don't have the the they can't you
know have
they can't they can't consent to sex
right because they're too young but
somehow they can consent to having their
gender changed something don't add up
here yeah I think you know but you know
what that is sorry to cut you do you
know what that is that is down to
mothers yeah I was just about to say
like it's not down to fathers this this
whole example of women leaders there's a
common trend of of women leaders in
history even dates back to the Bible
times
uh estar in the Bible came into
premiere's uh premises power when there
was a terrible time
in history so
you see we have we have examples of
America in um in Germany Germany has
recently come out of a bad history I'm
sure we will know
it doesn't speak to me that a woman can
do the job there it just says the
masculine men are not fulfilling their
roles that they should you know it's not
enough men you know what happened if
women are in power they'd be like Oh I'm
not talking to that country because she
did that
she didn't come to my birthday she said
something about my shoes that I didn't
like my feelings you know you know how
we know whether we're in a patriarchy or
a matriarchy it's by who do we cater to
more
yeah who who do you think understands
the under other gender more do men
understand women or do women understand
men
um can I just say something so I feel
like with my answers before I was saying
that like women can run the same role
whereas everyone in this room was saying
no men can't women can't do the roles
that men do only men can do those roles
so I feel like everyone no yeah that's
not what we're saying I feel like it was
I can clarify because everyone was
saying that because a woman can't do
that a woman can't do that that's a
mantra a woman doesn't want to be doing
that I'm saying women don't want to they
don't choose to because there's no law
stopping us from doing it and we don't
choose them that's very different than
saying we can't but women are choosing
them no no they aren't if you go to the
Scandinavian countries right
Scandinavian countries the most
egalitarian countries that are on the
planet right where men and women are
more equal they've done these studies
they said men and women are more equal
you have the right to choose exactly
what you want to choose do you know what
happened they became more divided
because the men went to certain
industries and women went to certain
industries men went to the stem Fields
science science technology engineering
and Mathematics women went to healthcare
social care stuff like that babies
nature so so so even when women get the
chance to do the same things that men
can do they don't do it goes back to
Nature you heard what what's happening
in the Scandinavian countries right like
um they've they're banning men for
bringing
um Asian wives because the women they
don't like it they don't want to date
them anymore yeah yeah like it's
actually they actually banned it like
shout out y'all that whole like the
whole like Thai Community is is in
uproar because
they have like they they can travel
there but they're not allowed in that
specific country because is that because
of women enough well they don't like
that because men men don't want to date
them they they rather go into these
other countries the women are more
feminine the tender swindler doing the
Scandinavian countries right I mean
we're serious yeah it's easy it's like
prime prime material for scamming like
you know like yeah
um okay so I have a question
going back to like the father's thing
why is it when would you guys agree that
if a father abandoned his child he's a
deadbeat
is incompetent man yeah like yeah just
yes or no yes yeah yeah just like
overall yeah okay why is it when a woman
aborts her child they call it her choice
that's a living modern day double
standard because she's just as bad she's
worse in my eyes I mean I've got my
opinion on that but yeah my body my
choice in it yeah yeah but why she's a
boat in it they're all based on
circumstances
well I mean 40 of women that have had
abortions have had two or more so I
can't seems like it's a pattern at some
point what if the woman doesn't want the
man around
I I feel that like I feel like I
shouldn't I shouldn't have to pay if you
don't want me to round the kid
fair enough don't don't make me pay for
it then if you wanna as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible